لا شك ان الاستثمار في مقتبل العمر امر
مهم للغايه حيث يمكن الشباب من الاستعداد
للمستقبل بشكل افضل والحمايه من الضياع
للمدخرات الماليه وايضا بدايه طريق طويل
في عالم المال والاعمال هي احد اكثر
الغايات المهمه بالاستثمار في سن
العشرينيات بحسب تقرير لخبراء نشرته منصه
اذا علم الاستثمار عالم واسع يمكن دخوله
وفق الخبراء بمال قليل مع خطط مهمه
للطوارئ والادخار المستمر مع البدايه لابد
من سماع نصائح الخبراء لاجل ضمان عمليه
استثماريه مميزه وناجحه دون السقوط في
الاخطاء
[موسيقى]
بالفعل الواحد في مقتبل العمر بالعشرينات
من الممكن انه يكون ويضمن مستقبل خلال
السنوات القادمه حتى يصل الى عمري
وبالتالي لديه راس مال كبير او على الاقل
مشروع ناجح ممكن اكيد اكيد
سنوات العشرينات هي حجر الاساس بالنسبه
لاي شخص فالاستثمار في السنوات العشرينات
سواء استثمار في النفس او الاستثمار في
عمل مشروع معين هو اهم خطوه لانسان ناجح
كيف فمثلا الناس كثير بتفكر انه الاستثمار
بدايته لازم يكون في عندك اموال كبيره ولا
تكون عندك معلومات معلومات كبيره نفس نفس
الشيء فهو ممكن تفكير غلط نوعا ما مع
التطور التكنولوجي نحن شايفينه مع التواجد
لاي اي مع تواجد عده مؤسسات بتساعد يختصر
صار موضوع كثير مختصر وكثير سواء ماديا او
حتى من نوع الجهد يعني افضل الاستثمارات
او مجالات الاستثمار في هذا العمر بالنسبه
للشباب نظرا بانه ما بيكون في ماده او
مبلغ كبير للاستثمار هل منحكي عن مثلا ام
استثمار في عقارات حتى وان كان يعني
استوديو شيء صغير جدا ام ماذا ولا بالاسهم
حاليا صارت الاستثمارات متنوعه متعدده فكل
واحد مجاله كل واحد شهر لوين موديه فمثلا
ممكن يكون استثمار في الكريبتو طرق من طرق
الناجحه لكن حاليا بدها تكون عنده دراسات
مسبقيه الموضوع اذا في العقارات صارت في
كثير شركات بتسهل الامر حتى لو ما عندك
فلوس انك تشتري استوديو كامل ممكن تدخل
انت وجماعه في استوديو تستثمروا فيه مع
بعض فصارت فيه تسهيلات كبيره ماديه
وتسيرات حتى من نوع من الخبره كذلك
للاشخاص يعني
[موسيقى]